I was dancing to music you couldn't hear!
Hi, my boo!
Sehi!
Hi!
Oh, hiyao!
Oh, hiyao kozaiimasu!
Oh, chat broken.
Now you definitely won't hear it.
Oh, I want to drive by the train.
I'm excited to drive baby Raven welcome to membership thank
you Ohio Ohio are you ready to flex that driver's license
Minto oh yeah baby you don't even know today I drove and I
had road rage I had a road rage I accidentally honked at
somebody and i was like go and i didn't see that somebody
was crossing the street but to be fair they didn't have
their playground honestly understandable
and so so after they went i kept going sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry i was in the right no there's no way it's time
to do do do do do do do drift Muay, Muay, Vroom!
I was like, yeah, T-G-I-F?
Does that say?
Oh, I thought that said Minecraft on it for a second.
Minecraft!
That must have been the most adorable road rage ever.
No!
I should have doubled down.
Muay, Muay, Muay, Vroom.
Vroom, Vroom, Vroom, baby.
Rev those engines.
we're heading to
are you guys excited to be driving around Japan with me as
your taxi driver now depending on how you act I might say
that you are a reincarnated Japanese princess just like how
that happened to me do you like my sunglasses snake I
thought they were like very good cruising glasses don't you
agree class glasses that are good for cruising hello miito
and i was like yo yeah i'm ready to drive give me in there
baby let me get the driver's seat oh yeah let's go miito
let's go we're gonna take akiba by crashing all the npcs
there no wait can we go to akiba take us to the scale figure
store What does that mean?
Wow, I'm doing Taka!
Thank you so much!
Wah!
For the 20 years!
Thank you!
Can we go to Akiba?
For real?
I'll give you guys another tour.
Akiba trip, count me in.
Not to be confused with the Akiba's trip.
Wah!
What was I gonna say?
Oh!
Speaking of taking Akiba, it is six months of Densetsu.exe!
We plan on celebrating our six month anniversary.
Wait, is it next week?
Next weekend?
Next weekend.
Next weekend, Densetsu channel.
Definitely be there.
We have some cool things to talk about.
So, yeah.
The 31st.
Yeah, congrats.
Happy half anniversary.
Yeah, we're so excited.
Wow.
Six months already.
Feels like you did a lot so far.
A lot of stuff so far.
I know.
We have our 3D live coming up.
Like, are you going to play Subnautica with them?
I'd like to.
I don't know what we're doing.
I think we have some ideas for the streams, but it's not a
set in stone.
That's your car?
Wait, which one?
Did I pass it?
Yeah, a big concert coming soon.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I have to show you what was sent to me.
Or rather, sent to the group chat.
The Discord.
Look at this.
Hold on.
Sorry that you can't hear anything.
And when I click out of the game, it stops the audio.
of those types of games um look at this oh tree not just any
tree though it's a tree in front of the theater that says
den set to thought exe ledges a new july 24th
tree isn't that crazy well we're already on the we're
already on the the what are you call that a mark marquee or
what what is that exactly the board we're already we're
already they're already talking about us oh so cool right oh
my gosh so so cool happy six then set to here's to seven
pickled cucumber thank you civic type r in red nice Yeah,
MVP forever!
Forever!
I'm here to watch one Minto's quest to become racing queen
of Japan.
I was just thinking right before this stream when I was
putting my glasses on, I was like, man, I kind of wish I had
a racing outfit.
Maybe, maybe one day in the future.
That's my Oshi's name and life!
It counts!
Happy dance anniversary!
If we're going to Akiba, just drop me off wherever we sell
Japan exclusive transformers wild king toys they're
expensive to import i think everything's expensive to import
nowadays right depending on where you are probably ask
ashton i know gosh ashton's racing outfit is probably like
the cutest ever i love it i love it i love ashton
My kamiyoshi playing my favorite game Let's go, Mito Well, I
should say, probably Well, first of all, thank you for the
Silver Tap Phoenix!
But also, I should Say, this is my first time playing Like a
racing game like this So, we'll see how it goes I might get
distracted by pretty views We'll see Oh wait, no, this is my
second time I've played Deadly Permanition, my bad Why is
the game aspect ratio that way i don't know i was trying to
fix it and it like wouldn't work it's fine maybe don't worry
about it i could crop it but i don't know it's just like
being annoying to for me
not enough movie trivia zero out of ten i could tell you i
could tell you trivia uh did you know In that one scene of
Lord of the Rings, when he kicks the thing, he breaks his
toe.
And that is actually his real scream.
In-game resolution set to 766 by 908.
Yeah, that's actually the size of my monitor.
So, whatever you just said, that's the size of my monitor.
Actually, it's one pixel below that.
7, oh sorry, 766 by 909.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
Tell me you're not driving with a keyboard.
I'm driving with my hands.
New a drinking game.
Take a shot every time.
Anytime someone references Samir, you are breaking the car.
I wouldn't, I wouldn't, I wouldn't.
Are you peddling with your feet?
Fred Fiddle's foot fluff.
Fred A.
Fred Foonstone.
Are you playing with a wheel?
Now, I do have a wheel.
But.
I'm afraid of Jesus taking it.
So I'm using controller.
Actually.
I have a wheel.
But the, I don't know.
The last time I used it.
It was for, um, oh my gosh.
That, uh, truck simulator game.
And it was so frustrating to map out the different buttons.
That I, like, put it away in a box and never touched it
again.
Euro truck, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You cannot be serious, girl.
I literally am serious all the time.
Valid reason.
That's the actual reason.
I mean, that's the...
If I were joking around reason, the serious reason is Jesus
taking my wheel.
Does he do that often?
I mean...
That guy...
He's greedy.
He's... he's gotta... he's gotta take those wheels!
But it's fair.
You know what?
Densetsu's also greedy, because we're gonna take Akiba.
He's got a whole wheel collection.
Watch your wheels, everybody!
Can't wait to see all the crashes!
Bon!
You're still here!
Hi!
Thanks for the super chat.
No!
I don't think I'll crash.
But shall we try?
Wait, my controller needs to connect.
There we go.
Start game?
Minty, don't even have a driver's license.
I have a license to kill and it's about the same thing.
Break.
Accelerate.
What is rewind?
Steering.
All the important things, right?
Use the driving line to help you drive.
Hey, buddy.
Stay in your lane.
But you are going to love it here.
Fuji-san!
I have so much to show you.
You're going to need rewind?
There's just not enough hours in the day.
And guess what?
Jordan will be here anyway.
Oh, Jordan.
everything ready we've got the sofa to crash like a little
while i got the garage all set oh he's here gotta go oh okay
everything may said is true you would not believe this place
is he australian oh jordan i'll see you very soon does mean
to have to wait for the car to go to the junkyard to become
a ghost before she can drive it no there's a huge event this
week That guy doesn't know how to stay in his lanes.
Tokyo Dorifto!
Oh!
We're going?
Yippee!
I wish I could jump.
R-B-E.
Oh, okay.
No, wait, I gotta beat these guys.
What if I did a hard break right now?
I'm... I found a shortcut.
here at Horizon Japan.
So if you're listening in your car or you're kicking back on
the bullet train, well, enjoy your day.
If you hit every single post, you get a special score.
Rewind.
Whoa!
Wait, how do I stop?
Resume from here?
Whoa!
Woo, the bullet train!
Wait, this is so cool looking.
Oh, shoot.
Whoa, who was that?
They were going crazier than us.
Stay on your side.
Oh, wait, this is Japan, so we're driving on the left.
Whoa!
Is this, like, based off of a real road, I wonder?
I want to drive through here.
Exactly like this.
Plus one!
Like my jokes, right?
You're gonna have to show us around.
Okay!
Okay, so, okay!
me.
Let's do.
Lakamoto Midori.
Oh, Amidou Enchan, today's my birthday!
Wait, how do I say your name?
Gunsawa, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Oh!
Jump, jump!
Whoa!
Race to the bottom of the Alps.
Oh.
No, I don't need to rewind.
I just need to pass that guy.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
It's so pretty!
Where is this?
Hey, get out of my way.
I found a shortcut.
Oh my god.
I'm going too fast.
Again, if you hit... Oh see, they want you to hit the trees.
Swiss Alps Japan.
It's fine.
I don't need to rewind.
I'm first.
Second.
First in my heart.
Yeah, baby.
Oh, oh yeah.
Stop spraying that.
I can't see.
Oh my god.
Weep.
Okay, one second.
Oh, oh, stop spraying!
That stuff is getting in my eyes No, they're doing it on
purpose.
I swear Wicked trip.
Holy cow.
I think I won everybody sabotage.
Yeah They literally hate especially me
Deja vu!
Does this game have Yerobi in it?
I feel like it's, I mean, here it should.
Riding in the mountains of Gunma?
Sadly not.
I heard that, um...
Idol is in it, like that.
Yo, Asobi song.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow.
See, they want you to hit stuff.
They wouldn't put it in the road other way.
otherwise oh don't don't spin out i know how to drift is
fine i played mario kart
oh shoot i'm gonna go down the mountain don't worry i just
took out the entire some some poor small village just lost
oh i should have gone through the sakura they just lost all
of their um their phone lines I feel like the pedals should
be like flying up and stuff.
Uh-oh.
Oh, good.
Hey, get out of the... Where's my horn?
Oh, what it was at.
Oh, that was the e-brake.
Honkonk!
Out of the way!
Slowpoke!
Grandpa!
Oh, oh!
I always overestimate!
Oh!
No!
No, I'm the grandpa!
Press the right stick.
Oh, thank you.
Fly!
Oh.
Are we just gonna watch a rocket launch?
Wait, I don't think this is allowed.
What is happening?
No, this is fine.
Literally me.
We're back here.
Race to the festival!
See you guys there!
Coachella!
Yeah, boy!
It's so sensitive.
I love the grass.
It's what they mean when they touch grass, you know?
I got it!
Hey,
out of the way!
Oh, I'm slowing down.
Okay, guys, pro tip, running into things will slow you down.
Everyone is going to the festival tonight.
Everyone's going to the festival.
Including me.
Guys, I'm first in your hearts, right?
Oh, don't hit the people.
I need to pay attention to the road.
What?
Tokyo Tower?
Wait, where's Tokyo Skytree then?
Oh.
Whah!
They're doing it again.
Yeah.
The final stretch.
Me, me, me!
Oh me!
For legend material, the Verizon qualifiers are starting
soon.
What the heck?
What's behind the...
Wait, my game is breaking, I think, maybe.
What was that?
Wait, what just happened?
What is happening?
Oh!
Hold on, I'm gonna try fixing my window again.
Wait, give me one second.
Wait, will it let me?
Oh, it won't.
No, it won't let me!
Okay, hold on.
Hmm.
Yeah, it's like full screen now, but not really.
I wonder if, can I like, stretch it?
No.
Hmm.
It's fine.
Who cares?
Let's see.
What character do I want to be?
Hmm.
Who looks like super strong?
We crush the competition.
Look, I'm making a good looking driver.
What do you mean they're all ugly?
This is just a...
...
They're kind of giving Phasmophobia care.
This doesn't mean...
Like everybody's about to go ghost hunting.
It's just a bad angle, maybe.
Like this guy's definitely going in.
He's like...
What's the mission?
Okay.
There's this place haunted by.
A revenant.
Um, okay.
Let's pick some...
Okay, hold on.
This guy is like...
He does not know what's going on.
What?
I kind of want the guy that's like spacing out.
Like...
He doesn't even know his name, probably.
Oh, we have somebody that actually looks at the camera.
Why are they all looking that direction?
Like, why are all their necks kind of...
Why are some of them looking this way?
Some of them looking this way.
I don't understand.
Okay, I'm going to go with this guy.
He looks really confused.
I'm a fan.
Body type 1, 2, 3.
What's the difference?
I literally see no difference between these.
Pal, I love Upen.
Oh, thank you so much for the...
For the 15kitsa thank you!
The difference is in the knees.
Oh!
This one gives him, like, a crazy chest.
Holy cow.
He grows knees and boobs.
Yo, man, what's your...
What is your workout routine for these pegs?
Do default.
Oh, we can change his hair.
Oh, wait, oh, I thought...
This one's...
Can I make me?
Can I change the hair color?
It's me!
Welcome.
My hair is...
I feel like the silver looks a little bit better.
Nope.
Oh, wow, prosthetics?
Whoa!
What is this?
Oh, it's a hearing.
Hearing.
Well, me.
This is me.
Your character can be changed at any time by this.
Oh, wait, hold on.
This is where it might like scare me, right?
Hold on.
Okay, yes.
Oh, okay, it didn't give me the option.
We're fine.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh my nickname let's be slip stream we are slip stream Sam
wait hold on what else is there we got spanky sunny gym this
slip stream Sam is too good though wait we could be pudding
Oh, these are like regular names.
Wait, do you think they have mint?
My current name is Ruki.
I learned that in Ace Combat 5, there's English version,
Japanese voices, English voices, Japanese voices, and then
English JP version.
And in English JP version, they call you booby.
They call you booby.
Hi, Minto.
I usually like to donate to my Oshis when I went at
Blackjack, Today I lost pretty bad!
What's Nihau?
Can I get a feel better beam?
Feel better!
Bee!
I'm sorry.
If they don't have...
Wait, L-M-N-O-P-Q-R-O Okay.
O-M-R.
meh meh meh this is discrimination they don't have me they
don't have men oh but they have Naomi okay we will go with
slipstream I could be Miku
hey I can't believe we're all here make yourself at home
whatever you need just ask hey oh we've talked about this
for so long this guy doesn't know it he doesn't know what's
happening what's next mate glad you asked i know the two of
you dropped everything to be here so i got you both a little
care package everything you need to make the most of your
time here Thanks, May.
Oh.
When in doubt, explore.
Explore.
Whoa.
Wow.
Not talkable.
And document everything.
I can't wait to see what you both discover.
And I expect photographic evidence.
Okay.
Of course.
If you need a guided tour.
I've got you covered.
I'm sure you both want arms and cash.
But with your driving skills, finding a job- Raku Express!
What's the local racing scene like?
How about street racing at night in Tokyo City?
Wow!
I have one word for you.
Toge.
Toge!
K-truck love.
Yeah, I want to race in a K-truck.
made this is great thanks we couldn't do this without you
though someone forgot to bring a car what what do you mean i
forgot to bring a car i had to fly here no what am i gonna
fly my car too this guy looks like my twin brother
where are we anyway do i get to choose it's like pokemon
who's yours
my god pick your starter we have grass we have grass fire
type the other two you can use water
oh i feel like i have to go with toyota my papa is an
engineer at toyota so
jimmy on sylvia k's nishan toyota so how do you say that gt4
or jimmy
you get all three by the way jimmy scares me has such big
wheels i would be able to see lots though probably not
children probably would run over any kids
Jimmy?
Okay.
This is the first generation of the GMC Jimmy.
Rugged, powerful, and loves to go off road.
V2!
By choice, obviously.
Wow.
Get me in there.
Yeah, oh, get in the car.
Get in the car right now.
other yeah make this plate your own just so we know it's you
oh oh what should i do um oh
wait okay hold on i i have an idea hold on we're gonna we're
gonna do like a special little thing at the front first.
Oh, I like those.
We'll do this one, Tokyo Tower.
I've called my car Ace Combat because I'm dumb.
Okay, so now I don't know.
Actually, I might have too many, too much space for this,
but that's okay.
M.
Oh, wait.
I've been sitting.
F.
Okay.
Then, wait.
up.
MF.
Mint phantom.
Then.
Watch, watch, watch.
Oh wait, I think it's actually earlier.
Wait, hold on.
Numbers.
Three.
One.
Wait.
Oh, I just passed it.
Zero.
MF 310.
Minto.
That's how you would read it.
That's why March 10th is Mint Day.
Because Minto.
Yay!
Nice.
Never knew that.
Now you know.
Go to our school.
I'll say it's fine.
So, Minto Phantom?
Minto.
Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto.
Minto, Minto, Minto.
Yippee!
That works.
Now, let's head out.
As something lined up, we need first time to make your city.
Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto.
Sounds good, May.
Lead the way.
Psycho, no service.
Where are we anyway?
Oh, am I driving?
Jordan!
Oh, I'm coming up on ya.
Oh, block party.
We're going fast for, you know, we're like going crazy too,
like look at this.
I could go, oh, I'm losing.
Watch out, everybody.
I'm on the road.
We love Jimmy.
Oh.
Oh, bye.
Okay.
Argent!
Thank you so much!
Thank you so much for the rainbow!
We're okay.
Roadblock.
Change of plan.
Take a left to the stadium.
Okay.
Wow, wait, oh, Tokyo Tower!
There's a really nice park right, kind of, almost right
below Tokyo Tower.
I recommend it.
It's not, oh wow, it's like, it's not like right next to it.
I wish I could like look at it.
You have plenty of time to explore?
Okay.
I'll just follow.
Come on, Jordan.
Was it American?
This game makes me wish I could visit Japan so bad.
It's been a dream of mine since I was little.
It's probably as close as I'll get.
You'll get there one day.
I believe.
Oh.
Oh, do you think they're doing the crossing right now?
We're taking the right.
Watch the oncoming shopping.
Whoa.
they're not crossing it's fine oh it does kind of look like
the Ghostbuster car I've got us three a chance to race
around a new horizon event route it's just a taster but hey
surprise we'll be meeting up with a couple of my friends
they're the ones who help me organize this we're almost
there hi everybody we're driving we're going so fast I want
to pass May.
I want to be the winner.
Come on, let me win.
Come on, May.
Don't be a sore loser.
Come on.
I do have a license.
Oh!
Let me introduce U2S.
And TinkleSan.
When they're not at the workshop perfecting their builds,
they help set a purpose for the festival.
Oh, sorry.
One second.
I have a new route here.
Ready for testing.
We need you to make sure it's fun.
Make sure it's Horizon.
I'm crunchy.
It wouldn't really be Horizon if we didn't make it a race.
In case Faname...
No Faname being Green Slot.
What do you mean?
Faname being Green Slot is free!
Pretty sure it's free.
Should be free.
I'm crunchy.
Oh, I'm back to the normal.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Remember, this is a race.
So...
I'll stay as long as they let me.
So I can get in as many people as I can.
Oh!
It's idle!
Whoa,
you can see Fuji is so clear from here.
They made Tokyo look so, like, idealistic.
This guy's trying to run me off the road!
Actually, I'm trying to run him off the road.
No!
Oh, it's May.
That's my friend.
Wait, what do you mean I missed the checkpoint?
No!
The game is sabotaging me!
Oh,
I could rewind.
Wait, how far can I rewind?
Let me...
If I could turn back time...
If I could find a way...
To go back to first place and not be sabotaged anymore...
We're going back in time to...
Oh,
I just cancelled.
I don't know where that's gonna put me.
Oh, resume Oh, we're at Tokyo Station!
Yeah!
This is fake Akiba?
Maybe?
Nailed it.
Time Paradise?
This is your first racing game that you played in it?
Yeah!
Mario Kart?
Wait, no, my neighbors!
No, that made me Phantom!
Don't call me that!
Call me!
Slipstream Sam!
You guys aren't here for the racing.
You guys are here for everything else.
Don't worry about it.
Uh-oh.
As does the tune on that R32.
Good work, everyone.
Thank you.
Getting to race on an actual horizon track thanks enough
it's all practice hey the truth comes out no i've signed us
up for the qualifiers look at my car in that case next time
we meet i'll expect you'll have your wristbands so go
qualify mf ghost wait i just realized the new additional d
sequel is called mf go wait is it actually complete the
opening act welcome to japan they don't know i'm a I'm a
Japanese reincarnated Japanese princess ma'am we're here for
Domenke when can we expect your full force edition share
cover I guess that's your first racing game with licensed
colors yeah path to the festival and our first wristband
standing in our way is the horizon invitational so we need
I'm always down to try new genres again qualifier events
complete enough these and we'll have a place in the
invitational first step on the road to legend island better
get to it what do you want to do first can we go to anoshima
dirt racing
speed trap cross country wait
Oh, when overtaking mint, you want to make sure the undercut
and the checkpoint are done at the same time.
Also, the drip...
Wait, also, the drifting also affects said overtaking.
I thought that was a wrestler.
Huckleboot time attack.
What's this?
Oh, okay, that's the thing that we're working towards.
Hmm.
I'm interested in this one.
The cross-country.
Thank you, Mass.
farm cross-country race.
Okay, I'm in.
If we do well there, it moves us one step closer to the
horizon invitational.
Wait, is this where I can just kind of explore?
I don't have to follow the road?
Are you aware there's a streamer mode that will play stream
safe music?
Yeah, but what's the point of that?
I don't care if I get demonetized.
I think as long as I don't get, um...
That person should have absolutely...
Mister, you had a stop sign.
I take matters into my own hands.
Let's get his butt.
Oh, sorry, this is Japan.
Let's see, where can we go?
What is this?
My new personal best.
Excuse me.
Oh, the K-Turok is so cute!
Little baby!
Let's protect it.
Protect the baby.
I'm so sorry.
I gotta get out of here.
There's no cops in the game, so feel free to floor it.
Yippee!
I gotta play GTA.
Wait, I feel like we're getting out of the city.
though redo redo there
you go
request forever meow sorry I gotta keep my eyes on the road
forever meow I want to be forever meow do you really want to
meow forever let's go find Akiba excuse
me so sorry that looks like the Shinjuku there.
I don't remember what it's called exactly.
Recalculating Root.
Are those real players right there?
That... Oh, sorry.
What is this?
Not Tokyo Dawn.
Oh, they are real.
Say if you see yourself.
Wait, everybody meet up right here.
Everybody meet up right here.
Meet me at the...
That was so cute, what was that?
Oh, sorry.
Wow, look how cute those are!
Menace to the roads of Japan.
I'm never driven in Japan.
You have to invite them.
Oh.
I see.
Hmm.
Oh, it's a collectible.
Wait, there's one right there.
Oh.
I'll
go.
Excuse me.
Bronson!
Thank you so much for the love and thank you for this!
They offer up credits too.
So, if you see one, you know what to do.
Uh-oh.
I'm stuck.
Alright, let's go get another one.
Uh-oh.
Oh no!
People are terrible drivers nowadays.
Look at that accident that they caused.
Oh my god, how embarrassing.
Oh, sorry!
I missed him.
We're fine.
There it is.
Locked on!
Oh!
Oh, hi!
I'm sorry!
I almost murdered people!
Look at his...
He's just like...
There's no idea what's going on.
Okay.
Shall we?
Wait, turn around?
I thought I was supposed to...
See, that guy's driving crazy too.
Turn around.
I'm like those people that, like, stop in the middle of the
highway.
One of those people that turn in the middle of the highway
so that they can, uh, so that they can don't miss their exit
they just put that there but what where sakura zaka no way
we have sakura zaka songs on here formerly kiyaki zaka 46
oops so a psychopath no oh okay they that actually was not
my fault.
Near miss.
So what's the best technique for drifting?
Teach me, everybody.
I only know the button in Mario Kart.
There's a button to drift.
You break into it?
Okay, so basically what I'm doing, but I just have to time
it better, right?
Oh!
Sorry.
Oh, I drifted!
Unintentionally.
Eto region.
Switch to manual?
I don't know what that is.
Roller coaster road!
Whoa!
I'm getting crazy speed right now.
Holy cow!
I don't think I'll ever slow down.
I don't think I can...
I drifted!
Great drift!
Ultimate rest!
Oh wow!
I got so many points, you guys!
What's my perks?
I have perks?
You can use your skill point here to unlock perks.
Every car has its own set.
bonuses skill points can be spent on any car you own float
like a butterfly to unlock this perk oh okay you first need
to have unlocked an adjacent perk
the game sabotaged me oh hello friend was that an Itasha
wait how are you so good how wait action what does that mean
wait what's your Whoa!
It's me, Tasha!
You've just been challenged to a head-to-head.
Ew.
No, don't...
Don't... Get away from me!
They're coming after me!
They know I'm a predator!
On the streets!
Wait, that sounds even worse!
I mean, that I'm like an apex predator!
That I'm... that I'm gonna...
Show them how to beat your Jimmy!
I don't...
Oh, it's true.
I gotta turn around.
What is this song?
It's cute.
Oh, it's just for the radio.
I didn't mean what I said.
Oh, wait, this is where we can practice.
Wait, this is kind of great.
Okay, here we go.
Watch this.
this.
Oh, that's a building.
Sorry.
I was looking at over here.
I messed it up.
Oh, everybody else is practicing too.
Let me join in.
Okay, here we go.
Watch.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, that That was pretty clean!
That was pretty clean!
This car is much faster than the one you're currently
driving.
Try the e-brake.
Game changer.
Wait a second!
Game changer!
Oh!
Nice.
I wonder how far into the woods I can go.
Off-road driving.
Wow!
The flowers and everything!
Where are we?
The E-brake changes everything!
This
is also really scary.
I like these trees are basically like...
So easy, so flimsy.
Great drift!
It's sad.
Get out of my way!
That was clean!
Whoa!
Where?
And...
Wait.
Not a bad job if I do say so much.
mascot behind me I didn't see she cooked she cooked I always
when he get it is it this one hold on everybody ah it's the
regional mascot for this area cute obligatory My log!
Where was it?
They said that I reached my destination, but...
Oh, over here.
You think people were trying to...
That one guy was trying to race me.
This guy here, but I gotta say, we get the minto pinto in
this game.
From the designs I've already seen, I think it's definitely
possible.
No way!
They see me coming up and they're like, close the gates!
Close the gates!
Oh!
Sorry, everybody!
Where are they going?
Wow!
I have to complete the qualifiers.
Sorry, I didn't realize there was a...
I didn't realize...
a hill there.
How do I start?
Excuse me, everybody.
Press X on the thing.
Oh, okay.
That's a bonus board.
The festival crew have placed a whole...
Oh, it's at the main row.
To help festival drivers gain a little ground outside of all
the events.
Thank you.
Man, the radio on this game is great.
Oh, I see it now.
Enter event.
Horizon qualifies.
Start here.
See you at the starting grid.
Solo.
Buy recommended car.
What do they recommend?
Rare.
Not the epic cars.
Hmm.
I'm gonna go with my Jimmy.
Big old truck.
I know.
I'm gonna go with my Jimmy.
We only have the common Jimmy.
I know!
How could they call him that?
that they really are well no we have the the raptor oh this
one probably is easy to drift in though no because it's
really low maybe we should get that it's epic i only have i
don't have so much money if i buy this this is all i got
jimmy okay we'll go jimmy she's what you got My Jimmy.
Alright, look at him.
Brand spanking new.
Not even a scratch on him.
I'm nervous.
It's my first race, you guys.
Oh.
Oh, they're looking at me.
Toon my car.
This game is...
I mean, this is what people...
Holy cow!
I never knew that it was so...
Wow!
So, like...
Wow I'm not gonna touch anything I just like to look
Wow the customization is crazy what the heck okay I'm gonna
do my best yeah I get super the tire pressure and everything
I like how many people gather for these I'm a big fan
weeeeee oh my god
Oh, yeah.
Whoa!
Jordan, get out of my way.
Jordan, you get back here.
Oh, no!
I got sabotaged!
Oh, no, I'm last!
I will never forgive you, Jordan!
Oh, rewind.
You're so right.
No, it was all Jordan's fault.
I never do anything wrong.
Hold on.
Here's me.
Here's me backing up.
Go find it.
There we go.
See?
It was him right there.
Oh.
Yeah, resume from here.
Whoa.
They're right on my tail.
Ah!
Oh my gosh, okay.
Whoa.
Oh, wheel drive, baby.
We're all just, like, in a line.
No!
Go!
Jimmy, you gotta speed up, buddy!
Jimmy, you gotta go!
Nobody saw the thing.
I'm going.
Oh, God.
Look at that guy.
Getting some crazy air.
Oh, oh, I forgot to let go.
There we go.
Oh!
I need to go back.
Actually, I need to go back a little bit more.
Talon, welcome to Membership.
What convinced you to join?
Is it my impeccable skills?
You'll never see anything like it again.
Shoot.
No, we're fine.
No, we're not fine.
The Joshua!
How did Gremlin get so much air?
How did he get up there?
I'm like nearly lost.
That poor sucker over there.
Could have been me, though.
No, I got the checkpoint!
What are you talking about?
What checkpoint?
Oh.
Okay, oh my god, stop, stop, stop, stop!
How am I supposed to get them?
Oh, shoot.
Sorry, I'm not used to that.
Yeah, go, go, go, go.
It makes it rewind so far sometimes.
Okay.
Thanks, guys, for teaching me about the rewind.
I understand it's important now!
I'm okay.
We're fine.
Oh, shoot.
I'm getting in there.
there no no Nordberg why
is him last this really is reminding me of Mario Kart hold
on we can overtake him
come on come on you're going so fast and yet wait
shoot sorry I should go to the left off you're new here I'm
a rookie I'm an absolute no I'm slipstreams down.
I'm just a rookie.
This is my anime arc where I become really great.
And one day I'll beat him!
My rival!
Yellow 13!
Oh.
Did I make the Qualifiers?
Anna?
The automated natural navigation assistant.
Let me run through the new features in my latest software
update.
Ask Anna.
In my latest update, you can now utilize the auto-drive
feature.
Auto-drive!
World Builder.
And the what's next suggestion feature.
Not me.
I'm 12.
Granny Turismo.
What's next?
Here, I will recommend what you should do next.
No!
I'm a free spirit!
This world is really good.
Chat didn't even finish.
You're right, you're right!
Select it, and I'll update your route.
Okay.
Okay, slipstream.
I'll set your route to the nearest time attack.
No, wait, I don't want to go there.
I guess it's fine.
Oh, wait, we're going to the chat.
cherry blossom though.
Oh, I'm just looking.
R for wreckin'.
Wait, where's that guy going?
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is!
Hold on, this is good for practicing my turns.
But like, I see like I over...
I do it every time where I go over.
Oh, extra.
Wait, what's down here?
Drifting is really slow.
But my anime shows it so fast.
I work on these games, happy to see you playing it!
What?
That's crazy!
Thank you, Jumbo!
100 yards.
Wow!
I wonder if the other racers are aware you're a time
manipulating god.
Whoa, this is a great shot!
Can Jimmy
swim?
Not even a little bit.
Snap a photo.
Oh, you're right, you're right.
She did ask for that, didn't she?
We've discovered 38 out of 671 roads, you guys.
So I got a...
Okay, hold on.
Let's get to a drift area.
Okay, here.
Oh, I was following them.
I don't want to follow their instructions.
I want to practice.
That is a lot of roads.
Up on the D-pad?
Oh.
What's that do?
Making use of the camera I gave you.
Ah, okay, cool.
There's so much you can do with it.
Get creative.
Experiment with the settings.
Share it to the world.
Wait.
My yaw.
I'm ying and I'm yawing.
How do I go up?
Oh, there we go.
What do I look like as I'm driving?
Pfft.
Wow, wait, this is actually a sick shot!
Look at the background.
With the motion blur?
Oh, I'm king of the road.
Nice angle!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Yeah, wow!
Okay, exit.
Yeah.
Biggest, most important thing in driving in this game, don't
try to break.
Turn at the same time.
time.
Wait, really?
But isn't that what you're supposed to do?
Album cover.
For real.
Oh.
Sorry.
Dang it.
Break for... Okay.
Accelerate through turns.
So you break and then turn.
Okay, let me keep trying.
Let me keep... This is good.
This is a good area.
Slow in, fast out.
Okay, okay.
Well, I said I drifted a little bit.
Let's go.
Wait, I think I did that one too early.
Oops, that was my bad.
We're learning, we're learning.
Oh!
Wait, oh, oops, I turned the wrong way there.
My bad.
Oh!
Wait, why'd that guy get over?
Oh, I thought that was...
Whoa!
Wait, who are you?
That car just jumped in midair.
I don't know.
Okay.
Side swipe.
Where?
Alright.
Oh.
Ah.
I feel like I can't get the hang of it.
What is that?
This is an aftermarket car.
You can find them here and there.
Live on at a good price.
Make
the eyes go blip blip blip blip blip.
You know?
She's so pretty.
Definitely take this to a time attack circuit.
Yes!
There's more bargains out there.
I wish I could do it.
wish I could make the eyes go up up you know bye bye Jimmy
okay time to learn how to drive a new car wait can I test
here oh that's a time attack circuit drive through the
gantry to start the lap timer oh oh well i was already on it
okay oh shoot oh shoot we're okay it's okay don't worry
about it oh shoot we're fine we're fine What's, what's,
what's my, what's my goal?
Alright, we're here.
I got a new skill point.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, no, no game!
Um, don't worry about it.
We took that a little heavy.
No!
Oh, yeah.
Gotta break a little more.
Yeah, new car, so I'm like...
back on pulse and i'm so sorry everybody but i'm gonna play
this tune and then i'll go again because i promised scott
tyler i would watch him take on one of these new time attack
circuits at the festival oh i am i'm in the time attack
right now okay so you don't actually need anyone trackside
he just wants to be there for support okay wait that was
that was cleaner but it wasn't quite a drift now was it no
scottie let's get it
You got time to put a few more laps in if you want, though.
Nice turn, thank you.
You're getting better?
I'm just gonna keep doing it.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's how you improve.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, right.
Oh, you were faster on that split.
This is a great way to see where you've improved.
Oh, shoot.
I did not drift at all.
Oh, there I did.
Somehow.
Playing it safe.
We did a little bit.
But I'm...
Oh, the hell are you, Kirito!
Oh my god.
He threw me off.
No.
That's the beta player.
No, that's the beater.
That's the beater.
Wait, I might beat my time.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
I'm up here.
You just posted a faster lap.
Dare to push it even more.
Wow!
Yeah, well it's because I didn't crash that second time.
First time I crashed.
Oh my gosh!
Okay.
No wreckage.
But it could have been cleaner.
It could have been better.
Break until the red line disappears.
Whoa!
That's such a good tip!
Thank you!
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, that wasn't my fault.
Whoa!
I always feel like I sound like one of those, uh, um, what's
it called things?
The, uh, those tubes that go, whoo.
Whoa, whoa.
Aw.
You can keep lapping as much as you like.
Whenever you want to move on, stop the car or drive away.
Not quite your best time.
Focus up, try again.
No!
That was time attack.
I'm sure you'll be back for more laps.
But right now, open your map up.
Mm, mm, mm, mm.
You're well on your way to the horizon.
The grown tubes, yeah.
Let's take a look.
Try in first person.
Can you actually?
You can track your progress at horizon in this rather handy
journal may gave us have a look through it and then let's
head out thanks jordan lucky you looks like you got a reward
i do is that x oh thank you applause wait what's my horn
sound like don't sleep on the radio stations out here so
much driving music to enjoy have a scan through how do i go
to first person oh our
whoa watch my
Whoa!
Jordan, thank you!
Today is a good day to be named Jordan.
Nice hand tricks, thanks.
Breaking news!
You have a mint...
Oh, a mint what?
Library available on the new Toyota Supra.
I just installed it and it looks amazing.
Wow!
Which way to the nearest party?
Oh, I need to try the e-brake on this thing, huh?
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait.
How do I get out of here?
I'm lost.
Guys, where's the exit?
Oh, my gosh.
Whoa, what's happening with my car?
I can make sure that...
I've also got some incredible local radio stations.
Left?
This way?
I'll keep going this way?
No, I'm not playing with a wheel.
I'm playing on controller.
Oh, this is like some...
This is straight driving music.
Why isn't your car green?
I thought you bring the color.
I found this!
This was a good deal!
What are you talking about?
Oh wait, I'm back on the time attack.
Oh, maybe we can leap here.
Wait, I'm going to go drive along the seaside with this.
Ooh, it's bumpy.
You can paint it?
Oh, you can?
Oh!
We're fine.
Everything's good.
And you can put decals on it.
I saw that guy with, like, the anime ones.
I couldn't see.
I couldn't tell what it was.
Wait, the Super Chat was saying there's a mint Itasha
uploaded for...
Oh!
I want to see.
Toyota Supra has a minto Itasha.
I'm in the game?
Who put me in the game?
Now I have to get the Supra.
Where am I going?
I want to get...
Holy cow!
That e-brake is insane.
Oh.
Meow.
Wait, hold on.
Actually, I want to try that again.
That was better.
We're, like, headed to the mountains.
Wait, hold on.
Okay.
Oh, close, close, close.
Close, close, close.
Oh, shoot.
I'm drifting again.
Okay, okay.
Almost, almost, yeah.
Ah, so close.
Wait.
Ryden.
That guy's name is Ryden!
Hi, that was me.
I'm in the 2020 Toyota Supra.
Mitra Graciously provided the arm for it.
Thanks, Dashie!
Thank you!
Oh, where am I?
I'm in the fields.
Wow.
A little off-roading doesn't hurt anybody.
Where are we?
Hmm.
Just posted a pic on your going live tweet.
Happy to see you in a miara, minto.
My rice.
I know.
Did I make any issues with the farmers?
I sure hope not.
Anna!
What's next?
Drone mode?
What is that?
Hey, you know you can see Japan in a whole new way?
The drone can be used to explore from different heights to
help you see things from a different perspective.
And try again.
Now you see that thing in your car below the console?
What is that?
That's a radio.
Eggy.
It's a little egg.
Wow.
Oh, now this is like the soundtrack for...
I can't go high, though.
I wish I could go higher.
This game is so pretty.
What the hell?
Oh, my God.
I just got home after brain surgery.
I think I can still drive better, though.
What do you mean?
I've never gotten in an accident.
Ever.
Yeah, this game looks so awesome.
Oh, why are there so many people here?
Oh.
Oh, they're like hanging out.
They're like being little boyfriends and stuff.
Sorry, I was practicing.
That was not so bad though.
That could have been cleaner, but it wasn't so bad.
I like how we get points for hitting people.
It's like it encourages it.
Ugh.
I don't know where I'm going.
I'm trying to get back to Tokyo.
Excuse me.
Oh, sorry.
Awkward.
Well, one of us has to go.
Thank you.
You get points for almost hitting, but not hitting.
Well, there was the one that said trade it.
Oh!
I'm in the field!
Where am I?
Wow!
Okay, how do I do another thing?
Let's go to Anna.
Anna, what's next?
Okay, Slipstream.
What do you want to do next?
Let's do...
Road racing.
Okay, Slipstream.
I have set your route to the road.
road race event.
Now I'm adding a page to the back of my guidebook which says
horizon drivers are very friendly.
They can be found all over Japan.
There we go.
Slipstream Sam.
That's the name.
Don't wear it out.
Look left.
Look right.
I don't want to auto drive because I want to practice, you
know?
Oh, shoot.
I gotta get it tighter.
I'm trying.
Let me try not e-breaking.
All right.
Shoot.
Oh, I got perks.
Oh, what's this place?
Wait, was it?
My perks?
Oh, I missed it out.
Dang it.
Oh, this guy.
Oh.
Alright.
Oh!
I was just trying to get around that car, but it was so
close!
Oh,
shoot.
I did it too early.
Okay.
Oops.
We got this.
You can access perks from the menu.
Got it.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Okay.
Oh.
I did it in time.
That's Hilda Red, though.
Prologue.
Wait, what's that?
Hmm.
I thought it was split stream.
No!
It's...
Slip...
Stream.
Prologue.
What's this?
Is this the same thing that I saw before?
Hey.
I know you won't hear this until you land.
Wait, hold on.
Get me out of here.
Oh, but you are going to love it here.
It's just the intro everybody Sorry, I got excited for
something.
I have so much to show you There's just not enough hours.
Oh wait.
How do I get out?
Let me skip and get skip Jordan here skip skip.
I've been busy getting everything ready.
Skip Skip skip I got the garage all set.
Oh, oh my god.
I'm just stuck stuck
I think I've seen this intro before.
Why is it all the way here?
Skip, skip, skip.
For some reason in my brain, I was like, oh, it's the
prologue to like another story.
Skip stream, me though.
We managed to find something I didn't know was in the game
and I explored the map plenty.
Look at me!
I'll show you how to play a game.
new car do you guys like my microsoft picture minecraft quit
event return to free room
minecraft minecraft
we were here okay slipstream i have set your route to the
road race event Oh, wow, she...
When did my eyes open?
Beautiful!
Yeah, I'm busy.
Thanks.
Don't bother me.
I'm busy.
I
didn't do it soon enough.
We can get out of this.
You okay?
You okay, Minto?
It's this one at a bath, obviously.
Where are we?
Oh, turn off.
No, no, no, get me out of here.
Where was I supposed to turn left at?
Oh, I think right here.
Yeah.
Hey, stop pushing my debris!
This way.
Yeah, the flower fields look so nice.
Nice.
It would be a shame if someone drove through them.
Here he is.
I'm going to get him.
Cute.
Yeah.
You won't think I'm so cute after you see this.
Watch.
Watch this.
I'm going over 100 miles per hour.
And I'm gonna...
Watch this?
What am I doing wrong?
Just need to get the feel for
it.
No, actually I don't have the assists on.
I actually said that I didn't want them on.
I did a little bit.
That was good!
Yeah, yeah, that felt- that was good!
I just gotta do that a hundred more times.
Why did it call me a daredevil?
Oh!
Right, that was great!
Oh shoot.
If you want to drift then you should break while drifting.
Oh, we could try it.
You just gotta do it a little bit.
All right.
What?
Where's my car?
You know, my miata's too fast?
What?
There are restrictions.
No, I'm nerfed!
But I just learned how to drive the Miata.
Okay, hold on.
We can do this.
Okay.
Let's go.
We got this.
Why are you putting me all the way back here, huh?
Lord Bones!
No?
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh, I did it!
I did it!
Oh my gosh.
Go, go, go.
They're all so fast though.
Duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh.
How are they so fast?
Minto racing.
Oh shoot, ouch.
No!
Lord bones!
I won't let you.
A ghoul license?
I got your license.
Right here!
Oh shoot, oh shoot.
We're fine, maybe.
I didn't realize, oh, we're okay.
Kinda.
I'm all right.
We're okay.
We recovered.
No!
Oh, I thought you were Lord Bones.
I don't want...
I won't let you!
No!
I was in half place!
Uh.
Oh, shoot.
I should have broken more.
Wait.
We're okay.
We recovered.
No, we didn't.
No!
Yes!
Song Owens.
Yeah.
Oh shoot.
Queen Racing.
Dude.
You jinxed me.
No!
Make top three?
You're asking a lot of me!
I'm half place right now!
You're asking a lot of me right now!
I can't I can't get past this guy He's too good You're right
on my tail Okay Go go go Half place
Oh poor jingle jangle joe All the way at the bottom Sneak
venom Second place
You don't not laugh!
Snake Venom 5789!
Is
your difficulty setting super high?
I don't know.
Is your car customized?
How do you reach the pedals?
What the heck?
I can reach just fine!
Oh yeah, baby.
We killed that.
Wow, they're hula-lo.
You skipped the lead.
Why?
The AI in this game are super hard.
The devs said they're looking at it.
Really?
You know what that reminds me of is people complained about
in Tomodachi Life, the new one, that the me's were too
friendly with each other.
And so apparently there was a new update and now everybody's
me's are getting divorced and they all hate their children
and everything it's just like crazy some cars are
dramatically better at drifting than others choose cars with
reared wheel drive thank you i'll look i'll try the divorce
update yeah
for the horizon 6 if you need help on pr since i got tune
code top 35 in the world also extreme track toys is the best
category you spoke a different language to me Joshua but I
really really appreciate it thank you day trip wait this is
so fun okay slipstream I have set your route to the next
maze day trips I want to go on a day trip wait where's my
miata how can I change
Look how cute the buildings are.
He has the source code.
Start menu.
Ah, here we go.
Thank you.
Change car.
Me harder.
Get in the car.
Add to my favorites.
Oh, it's got a little heart next to it now.
Get in the car.
She's indeed a long way before that.
I'm right here.
You have arrived at your destination.
Do we ever need to, like, get gas or anything?
Fill me up, please.
In Japan, most places, they fill your gas for you.
It's one of those types of places.
Also, isn't it...
Um...
Oh my god!
Let
me get a good look at you.
Wait, wait, don't disappear.
Don't disappear.
Yeah, yeah.
Ah!
Yeah!
So good!
Wait, what's the front look like?
Turn, turn.
Back it up.
There you go.
Thank you.
Wait, oh.
Wait, how can I...
Oh.
No!
Oh my god, it even has the Den Setsu logo!
That's Crazy!
Oh, yeah, how do I go into photo mode?
Uh, what was it, B?
No, no, no, no, no.
Good company.
Gear on Horizon Wave.
Oh, there it is.
Up.
Oh, up on the D-pad.
Thank you.
Sorry, I forgot.
Oh!
Wait, this is so awesome!
Oh, I guess I could just take photos, couldn't I?
What do you mean nothing new in the shot?
What's the license plate?
Oh my god, Denzitsu logo on the back too!
Oh.
Thanks.
Where is it saving to?
I could share it!
What's the other side?
Cute!
Thank you both going to find me.
Thanks for coming to find me.
Oh, your wheels.
How do you do that?
How you...
Don't do that again.
Oh, he disappeared out of existence.
He like crashed and then disappeared.
Oh,
are we doughnutting?
Yeah!
Did he disappear?
Those are some tight doughnuts.
Oh, there he is.
There he goes.
Bye!
Let's do the day trip.
There was a ghost car.
Yeah.
Discover Japan!
Listen up, daytrippers and thrill seekers.
I've got a special day trip planned.
It's very special cars just for today.
We will be heading out soon.
Taking in the lush forest, glistening lakes, and the area's
magnanimous.
and of course there may be a nice surprise lined up if my
good friend Jordan manages to keep his word a brat let's get
ready to roll out I'm in what is this all right boring rules
time please stay together I'll meet you wait to see what I
see and I don't want to lose anyone I plan this room
meticulously okay yeah I've been there before farmhouses
with hand-thatched roofs using passed down through the
generations techniques yeah set in this lush verdant valley
it's as if stepping into the past okay so she's a drill
seeker so where are we going I don't want you to miss
anything as we enjoy the day trip I want you to feel strong
so that's why I selected this convoy of four by four
vehicles legroom for days and made to taint any road Sato is
is taking over
the the um Clara get out of the way oh my gosh Clara is
being a bad driver can we kick her from the group
amongst our car selection today is the Mitsubishi Mata me me
well funnily enough it's called the Mitsubishi Shogun maybe
a more apt term for driving around the infectious of Japan,
but whatever you call it, this SUV has stood the test of
time.
My bud.
They also hit the wall to be fair.
The Shogun.
We have one of the world's fastest cities, and with the
arrival of
those enjoy being far away from the fast pace of city life.
I'm so involved in the trees.
It's to appreciate stillness.
Slow down once in a while.
But like we're going so fast.
Clara get it together girl my dad used to run a Mitsubishi
dealership so we had a Montero I love the assortment of cars
he can get in these games oh I thought it was me I thought I
was a special guest Mint Phantom.
Oh.
Would you guys drive in Japan?
I think I would drive if it's like the countryside like
this, but...
Definitely not in the city.
I would be terrified.
Yes, really.
It would be kind of scary though, no?
Do you know what the roads of Tokyo are?
you are like.
As you turn in, off to your left, you have a stunning view
of the mountain range.
Whoa!
Oh, shoot.
Sorry.
I was trying to!
I live in Jakarta.
Tokyo is a breeze.
Okay, that's fair.
Japan has many ancient tribes.
Be sure to learn about the customs and rules before you
visit.
These are places of spirituality, of peace, quiet, and
contemplation.
Oh!
You have a bow.
Wow!
I got one recently.
It's supposed to make your brain clear.
I have one for safety on the road and it seems to work.
Most people have one for safety.
Oh yeah, we overtook Clara.
Let me see.
Is she running into me?
This bitch!
Sorry.
May, I lay down a challenge.
A race.
A simple race.
No twists or gotchas.
Alright, I'm in.
Just so you know.
I'm kind of a throw on these roads now.
So try to keep up.
What a perfect challenge.
Now, I know.
May says stick together.
Stay in close fire and alert catchphrases.
But this is a race.
So ignore all that.
It was such perfect time.
for the cutscene.
Wait, what am I in?
Oh my God.
Ah!
Oh my God, I don't even...
See ya, May.
May!
Get away from me!
Oh shoot.
Ouch.
That was a head-on collision.
Man,
oh, oh, we're here, we're good, we recovered.
We recovered?
The family is deceased.
No, no.
I did an ultimate drift just now, you guys.
I did the ultimate drift.
That was a, that felt like was a good, oh, awesome drift.
What's he gonna say?
I feel like that one was pretty good, too.
Oh shoot.
Oh.
No!
I need that.
Wait, this is your business.
Is it not made?
Like you offer the day trips?
No.
Okay.
You didn't make it.
What do you mean I didn't make it?
Ah!
Conflict of interest.
One more time.
One more try.
You didn't make it!
Okay.
Now, I know, May says stick together.
Stay close by and other catchphrases.
But this is a race, so ignore all that.
Oh, shoot.
I'm doing poorly already.
Screw you, Jordan.
Yeah.
Yes!
No!
That's how it's done, baby.
You make them crash into the other cars.
If they commit crimes, then your crimes don't look so bad.
Shoot.
Wait.
She's a menace.
No.
Oh, gosh.
Ah!
Don't do it, Jordan.
Don't do it.
Wash up.
I messed up!
Oh, I messed up.
No!
I'll never win now!
No, I had such a good lead!
No!
Lucky escape!
Oh.
I really messed up here.
Oh god.
I'll never win!
I got too cocky!
I'm not gonna make it!
Okay, what about Takahiro or whatever his name is?
He's last!
Let's go again!
Why do I feel like you can cheese the event?
I feel like though it doesn't say that there's checkpoints,
but aren't the little flat, like the the bursts.
Rewind.
Now, I know.
May says stick together.
Stay close by.
Another catchphrase.
I forgot about Rewind.
You're right.
I'll never have such a good run that I just did, though.
Like, this is a checkpoint, though.
It doesn't say so, but...
That guy was on the wrong side of the road.
Am I crazy?
that was like perfect though i had them both hit two
different cars use the off-road power
i don't even know how to get there wait maybe like this
i think i made it
oh shoot they're like right behind me still though that's
kind of How?
How the hell are you still behind me?
How?
Did they follow me?
Skip the you here?
Finish line is close.
Winner gets a free day trip pass.
Oh, shoot.
I'm in the...
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
I'm still first.
Yay!
Thank you, everyone, for being such great day trippers.
You've been wonderful.
guests and races no problem mate and anytime have a safe
journey home all and I'll see you on another nice and chill
day trip where's my free day trip three stars perfection
yeah put me call me call me the queen of the road earn three
stars on any day's trip story chapter I'm a dedicated to
Okay, slipstream.
What do you want to do?
I feel offended by that title.
Hated tourist.
New drivers find things nobody else can.
It's true.
I'm a dedicated tourist.
Whoa.
Oh, my miata's back.
Seems like you got on well with that health care.
Thank you.
I feel fast.
Now, how do I get to Tokyo?
You drive like a raging bull.
I love it.
What was that?
What's going on in here?
Whoa.
K-truck.
We're just exploring now.
I love the free room.
I love the fact that there's free room on this.
It's actually so awesome.
Let's go to Tokyo!
Tokyo!
Tokyo Colleen!
Wait.
I'm just gonna see what the sign said.
Some bridge.
Narrow bridge.
There's a map of my heart.
Hiiwi
man, don't look.
I'm embarrassed.
Miata drivers and car appreciators.
Everybody who appreciates cars
Can watch and see how great the car is that I drive See
everything that you can do with it What I do in the game you
can do in real life
How do you How are you supposed to recover from an e-break
Drift?
That's what I want to know How are you supposed to recover?
Is it a joke?
This is the wave.
Great drift!
Whoa, where's this going to?
Drift.
Better breaks help.
Tap it just a little.
Oh!
Did you see that?
I did it!
Wait!
Wait, I did it!
I did it!
Wow!
Wait, that was like a great...
Oh my god!
Yeah, that's it!
Wow!
I wanna go to the hot air balloons.
I think it's so funny that this game makes Japan feel
like...
Like, two feet wide.
You could see Mount Fuji from everywhere.
I mean, it is true, you can see Mountain Mount Fuji from
Tokyo.
Which is kind of crazy to think about.
Like, Fuji is just that huge, you know?
The only thing left is throttle control, but that's more
advanced.
Oh, tiny region!
Shohei.
Wow, I can't believe he's so famous.
They named their whole region!
After him.
Guys, I got a new skill bar.
Wait.
Kiwi man, don't look.
Skill point issue or something like that, right?
Wait, is it under store car packs?
Oh wait, are these like you buy, oh wait, no.
K-Truck!
Wow.
Are these with real money?
Whoa.
Look at him go!
DLC.
I see.
Should I dream of come too?
Vembo ship, thank you!
Wait.
Where are my skill points?
I'm looking.
Collection progress?
No.
My cars?
My horizon.
Cars tab.
Tune your car.
Oh, here there is car mastery.
Hmm.
Wait.
I have to unlock it for this guy now.
Oh, I see!
5% more skill score from Drift and E-Drift Skills.
You have just unlocked a permanent perk.
This applies a permanent bonus to this car.
Drafting?
What is drafting?
10% more skill score from show off.
Your skill chains just got tougher.
Now they only break after two collisions.
Wait, what?
My skill pins are going to break.
Oh, follow closely behind.
Oh, I see.
I'm learning terminology.
I would drive directly into the lake with you.
Don't do that.
What if somebody told you to jump off a bridge, would you?
If I told you to drive into a lake, if I told you to jump
off a bridge and then dive into the lake, and then drive
around donut style, and then do a flip, would you?
Say no.
How big is this bridge?
Have some dignity.
You had me at donut style.
Are you telling us to do that?
No!
I'm not a bad influence.
I'm a good influence.
You have to treasure your life.
Don't throw it away.
My horizon.
Message sent.
Wait.
Is this from people?
Oh.
Gifts.
Hey.
Where are my gifts at?
We would literally follow you into hell, boss.
It came with the Ibu contract.
So what if one day I became so evil?
I had so much evil that I stopped being a ghost and I became
a demon.
And I was like, yes, come to hell.
You would do it?
Oh cute!
Welcome to Japan.
You had me at wood.
Wait, I want some of these.
These are so cute.
I want the bee.
Hot dog!
Reach level 40.
What level am I?
Zero.
Just getting started!
Gifto for Minto!
Oh, thank you!
Thank you.
Wait, the cat is so cute too.
Oh, dinosaur.
Complete 21 dirt races.
Alright.
Let's get us a dirt race.
Ducky.
I've earned 315 drift skills.
I guess we're storming the gates of hell with you.
Demon, Minto.
I'll become like Venom.
I'm into as long as you're there heaven wait hell is heaven
no hot dog mean thought over dignity you guys please
treasure cars treasure cars are a one-of-a-kind abandoned
cars around Japan oh I've got a bunch of photos that might
help you zero in on the location take a look at this one
uh-huh it might be nearby a charger I'm pretty sure a friend
of mine play golf around here see the golf carts keep an eye
out you'll have to search the railway maybe under the bridge
so that's how much you're cooking these days wow gosh what a
robot thank you so much for the 50 gifted thank you i guess
you'll know you're getting close once you feel a breeze a
breeze i recognize that waterfall There's definitely a
temple nearby.
Be on the lookout.
Okay.
World map.
Where are we at?
Whoa!
This is...
We went so far up.
Then we went all the way.
Oh.
So if I turn left.
And go down this road.
The river.
Yeah, the road by the river.
We can go down, down, down.
Back to the city.
Dongo.
What's this here?
This looks like a little place to practice.
Chat frozen.
Oh, thank you.
I'm starting to yawn.
Down, down, down by the river.
River split.
Speed trap, oh, I wonder, I wanna, now that I've like...
I was gonna say now that I've gotten better.
Can my car break?
I don't want it to, my miata.
Wait, I lost my license plate.
That's kinda scary.
Wait, hold on.
There we go, sorry.
Indestructible?
How do I fix it, make it look prettier though?
You're free.
16 months is an Ivo!
Peek of course!
Thank you!
You could fix it in photo mode.
Oh really?
Photo mode.
Holy cow.
Holy cow!
Sorry!
Change your car.
Okay.
I'll do it.
Well what if I join a race?
It might fix itself too, right?
You do the drive?
Threatening the needle!
Did you guys see that?
Oh, where am I?
Oh, I think I turned here.
Did you guys see that?
That was sick.
Yeah!
Okay, that's fine for right now.
We're alright.
Thank you, though, for everybody's...
Wait.
I see the city, I think!
Dejaboo!
Wait, you guys know I'm in a Toho Eurobeat.
Um, Tokyo Tower!
I'm in a Toho... not Tokyo, sorry.
Toho Eurobeat, um, single.
You should listen to my song.
Lost in the door!
Thank you so much for letting me get this!
Wait, we can play it.
Hold on.
Wait, if I were...
Where?
Where's in my gallery?
Me!
Wait, I forgot to save my other things.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Wait, top rated.
Whoa!
These are so...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna like this one.
You have success.
like this photo.
Wow.
The robot shows up later.
Spoiler.
Sorry.
Tokyo Tower.
Oh my god.
These look so good.
These are crazy.
Oh.
By boy.
This one's crazy too.
The speed.
Oh yeah, but that's gonna do we can listen to it but then I
don't I was looking for a way to turn down the music on here
it doesn't seem to be oh settings maybe audio let's do music
okay then let me pull up wait I kind of want to drive to
Fuji now I I guess we could.
We could try.
Should we?
Let's see.
Night of the Chupacabra.
Holy cow.
I didn't realize how many views this had.
What the heck?
La la la.
Don't forget to loop it.
Okay, I'll loop it until we get... Until we get sick of it.
Where is it?
Oh yeah.
Dumb.
They came from beyond the borderline!
Of the Chupacab!
Night of the Chupacabra.
Don't worry, don't worry.
What?
She'll be all 109!
Wait, this is close.
Terrifying ghouls and creeps.
Whispers of the fifth dimension.
Whoa!
Hey, now there's no need to feel any dread.
Would you rather solve the mystery ahead?
Oh, oh, yeah, oh, aren't you instead?
All stepped up, have a little
fun.
You came from beyond the borderline!
What's the night?
Oh, the chupacabras!
Oh,
don't worry about it.
Meet the starry night!
Let's go to Fuji!
Ayax, thank you so much for those!
Thank you!
Yeah, you can actually buy the single if you like the song,
so...
It's so fun.
I want more Eurobeat songs.
Uh-oh.
I think I didn't tap it soon enough.
Wait, where are we going?
I
like driving the Miata.
Oh!
Great song, great singer!
Lucky escape.
Would you rather solve the mystery of...
Oh, yeah, we are...
I'll haju and send!
Trying to tell people how to get the CD.
But filters hate.
Let's use Google...
Oh, sorry.
You can find it, yeah!
Chupacabura!
Chupacabu!
I know a shortcut!
Oh,
the mystery eyes.
Too big of a tree.
I thought
we're going to get a great picture down here, guys.
It came from beyond the borderline.
What's the knot?
Wait.
No, I thought it would fix my car.
Wait, reset, cause my...
There we go.
Yippee!
Uh-oh.
His neck is
broken.
Wow.
Time of day.
No.
Gale.
We'll go normal.
Car lights.
Enabled.
Wait, why does it say disabled?
But they're on.
Wait, can we make it really different color?
Whoa, holy cow.
The saturation goes crazy.
Let's see.
Whoa.
Wait, hold on.
Maybe we can get a good...
I want to get out of the...
Hold on.
What of the...
There we
go.
Chupacaburra.
It's me.
I want to be the focus.
Chupacaburra.
What if Fujisan's the focus?
Looks terrible.
Oh,
you can even control the shutter speed?
Holy cow.
I want more sunset vibe.
Wait, can I turn my...
It said...
Hold on.
It says disabled.
Oh, there they are.
Yeah!
Why does the car look sad?
No, it doesn't.
What are you talking about?
Character driver.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait, no way.
Oh,
it's too cool.
It's too cool.
Wait, hold on.
In the water?
I can't even say it now.
Chupacabu.
Where is he?
No, there we go, center front.
Nah, I liked it more in the water.
Yeah.
What a better look at the Miyada.
Beautiful.
Yippee!
Oh, today I couldn't pay attention to your yapping even.
with earbuds sorry that's okay but hearing the chupacabra is
lifting me a little i'm sorry pop up and down the headlights
you're so you're so right
chupacabra nice it got me grooving it was really fun dancing
i i get it like it's really fun
Um...
It's really fun driving with the...
Ah!
Oops.
Clear.
Wait, can I turn the brightness up though?
Oh, gosh, it's terrible.
If we do the contrast.
Down?
No?
Why is it so bad?
You want exposure.
Oh, there it is.
Yes, thank you.
Ah!
It's beautiful.
This Chupacabra setting in the late 90s It was Minto all
along If you like the Miata, unlock the FDRX7 It's much
cooler Oh, it's a beautiful This is the kind of look I
wanted There we go Yes Yes Wait, what else we had?
Oh Oh
Wait, why is it all weird now?
What happened?
Why is it so bright all of a sudden?
It's because...
Why did the exposure go up?
You can even change the wheels!
Oh, that's what...
Oh, yes, no, the right, the right look good.
Oh, my God.
Oh my god, it's art!
I kind of want to...
Hold on, let's move the car a little bit.
Okay, driving on the rocks is kind of...
What's over here though?
Can we see Fujisan well?
It'll reset if you touch too much water.
Oh, I can't see anything.
Okie dokie.
Wait, this is a different place.
Where am I?
Oh.
Over that way.
It'll just drive along the beach.
Until we get there.
Uh-uh.
Just don't touch the water.
Alright.
I'm a wrecking boss.
No,
I didn't mean to!
No!
Okay, try again.
Volt, what are you doing down there?
Okay, this is the last time I'll play the song too.
I don't want you guys getting sick of it.
Yeah, I have to be careful not to go too far over.
A bush?
I'm stuck on the bushes!
I know I need to build up speed.
I'm trying to get around them, to be honest.
No!
There we go.
Okay, maybe there.
Maybe there.
You shouldn't be playing copyrighted music.
And oh.
What are we?
The tree!
I know I need to get rid of it!
Wait, the tree's in the water!
Wait, okay, hold on.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, I saved my settings even.
I think?
Almost.
Kind of.
We'll do that.
We'll do that one.
Was it sunset or evening?
No, sunset.
And the exposure.
Oh yeah, my cosmetic damage.
We'll get rid of that.
Oh,
yeah.
Or exposure.
Paying an exposure.
I want to see what it looks like.
I'll
get better Oh wait I forgot We're getting paid an exposure
Yeah Crowd?
Emo is wait What is this?
Ew Wait, come over here?
What are you doing?
Waiting or blowing a kiss is your only option.
Oh sorry, I said I would...
This might be the worst thing I've ever seen.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say.
Please, oh baby, don't go simple.
and clean is the way that you're making me feel tonight it's
hard to
look you're giving me so many things lately you're all i
need oh whoa you're smiling me Don't get me wrong, I love
you But does that mean I have to meet your father?
When we are older, you'll understand It's enough when I say
so Maybe some things are that simple When you walk away, you
don't hear me say Oh, baby, don't go.
I wish I could put him in the water.
Simple and clean is...
Wait, maybe we can.
The way that you're making me real tonight.
It's hard to let it go.
I don't think we could do.
It's a little scuffs.
You see, I pressed twice and it, like, moves him around a
little bit.
I like that, see?
Maybe we put him over there.
I can't sing along.
It's too high.
If you want me to actually hear, if you want to actually
hear me sing that song, you can listen to one of my...
I think probably...
I think I sang it in the last karaoke I did.
The last karaoke stream, right?
You can unlock more emotes later.
That's huge!
all right let's do one more i wish now i wish i had the car
just to tilt it a tiny bit but hold on let me see if i can
do it back
to photobomb
the tree is still broken though wait if i do the cosmetic
damage does it fix the tree no it doesn't riku Whoa!
You can enjoy this game in so many ways.
The
dead trees.
Okay, some grass, some bush framing.
When you walk away, you don't hear me say, Oh, baby.
Let's try this.
Where did my pink sunset go?
It was pink before.
Am I crazy?
Where did it go?
It was evening.
It wasn't sunset.
Oh, let me try.
Oh, maybe it was.
Hmm.
It's pink.
Wait, now you can't see the leaves.
My angle is ruined.
That's okay.
Beautiful.
Love me too!
Thank you!
We're 16 months!
So much crazy detail for the photo mode.
I'm like...
Yeah!
I love it!
Actually, no, no.
Change.
There we go.
Actually, a little more exposure.
No.
Yeah.
Is that right?
No, I don't like it.
Oh.
I want it warmer, I think.
But I want to keep the pink.
So pretty.
The photograph, too?
Yavi!
Wait, what does...
I wonder what the sepia looks like.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Cinema.
Okay.
I think that's a bit better.
Whoa.
Trying to see what the difference is.
Less of the call.
So we'll put it back in the middle.
I'm just...
I'm experimenting.
Hmm.
But the car is not in focus.
It's at the focal point.
That's true.
Finding.
But I don't want to look down because I feel like then
there's too much...
Hmm.
Yeah, I'll reduce the aperture, you're right.
There we go.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah, I forgot about that.
Yeah.
I reduced aperture, increased black mesa.
That was a joke.
Haha, bad chance.
Anyway, this cake is great.
It's so delicious and moist.
Kacham!
They have the woololo horn and sound effects car horns.
Woololo.
Woolo-lo.
Does shutter speed flatten the water?
I don't know.
Is the water technically moving?
Let's see.
Cinema.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, let's see.
I don't think there's a way to, we do the slowest shutter
speed, we'll get like every, oh, that'd be so awesome.
Let's see it.
Nothing new in shot.
Yeah, I think shutter speed is just for the movement,
unfortunately, like a, like a car movement, hmm.
It does not.
Yay!
I'm so glad to have tried this game out.
I felt like I felt like I improved in just the couple of
hours that I played.
I will.
Is there like an online mode where you can like, you know,
if I made a race and then you guys could join?
Is that possible?
You absolutely did improve.
Yeah, it was so good.
Yeah, you can make a lobby.
Which you guys race.
Well, you guys probably would kill me, but that's okay,
probably.
That's fine.
You can kill me.
Hold on.
Sorry, Matara asked for something.
give it to her real quick.
Okay.
She's already dead.
You guys then would eat me alive.
You would eat me alive but it'd still be fine to play with
people.
Tell her she's stinky.
Also, oh yeah.
I'll say it in the group message.
Also, my chat says you're stinky.
Hey, set the drive.
Thanks for playing your song and letting you know your
cornering skills are getting really good yeah towards the
end when I was going through the city hold on let's get out
of here when I was going through the city oh and let's also
turn my music back on audio
I was I was not running into so much stuff what was the song
earlier oh that was night of the triple cover here you go
copy URL please go watch Please go watch!
And like leave a comment and be like, wait, actually...
Look at this.
A shortcut?
Whoa!
What'd you...
What'd you think?
Wait, who do you think has better driving?
This or Deadly Premonition?
Don't worry, I won't tell Zach.
Um...
I don't know, maybe...
Deadly Premonition?
I like I love the free drive so much the free room is so fun
that it's like hard to stop the car sounds so good in the
tunnel it sounds so good
The ocean!
What's the stream you drove like the free bird solo was
playing?
Free bird!
But... wait, I didn't read the rest of it.
What did you say?
But the second Chupacabra came on, you were a pro.
It's all about the tunes.
Thanks, Minky.
Thanks.
Oh, shoot.
I'm stuck on the trees again.
I don't have enough space to get.
Oh.
Are we at the ocean now?
Oh, that's a building.
It is all about the tunes.
Bye Vault!
Everybody's at the ocean.
Oh wait, this is a track!
Oh.
Wait, this is where we did that one!
Oh, with the rocket!
Ah!
Oh, the track ends eventually, everybody.
Hahaha.
How have you guys enjoyed me playing?
I had a lot of fun.
We're in the yellow stamp.
Wait, oh.
Oh!
Looks like you've been busy exploring and discovering new
places.
Here, I'll stamp your journal.
This is very fun!
Thank you!
Local 19 year old ghost dies for a second time after
launching her car off a cliff.
Fortunately she is a ghost.
The birthday merch arrived today, Fumito is huge!
She's bigger than my forearm, and this shirt is pre!
Thank you!
The 3D texture is such a good touch.
I'm glad you liked it.
I was really adamant about that.
The slippers are cute, they's...
Thank you!
I'm glad you like everything.
You'll pick up rumors of cars hidden in barns for you to
follow.
Oh, cool.
One of my faves games series, and it's absolute joy to watch
you play.
I hope you keep playing and become the Drift Queen.
Thank you!
Thank you, JT!
It used to be.
There you go.
Thank you so much for the pink!
I hope you have a great night and tons of fun at Fandomay
tomorrow.
Yes!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thanks for the streaming.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Bye, Bolt!
Wow!
Don't look at the state of my car.
It's fine.
Beautiful, beautiful!
I had so much fun.
Thanks for letting me be your tour guide.
We went through mountains and rivers.
I would go through mountains and rivers and lakes and oceans
to be- to see you guys and hang out too.
So, thank you.
Otsumito everybody!
Yeah, we could just buff these out.
What- what- what- why couldn't we?
You know?
Yeah, it's fine.
Otsumito!
It's a weirdo!
Weird, thank you!
Thanks for going to Fandom It is my very first con, so it
means a lot.
You three will be guests.
I feel really bad.
I can't go this year, so consider this a welcome to you
guys.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye-bye everybody!
Have a good day, have a good night!
Bye-bye!